season three of Netflix's hair 80s Syfy
series stranger things culminates in a
main character death or does it we're
going to take a look at the ending and
all-important post credits scene
spoilers are coming if you haven't seen
the season yet season three ends with
hopper David Harper and choice Winona
Ryder attempting to close the gate
between this world and the upside-down
hopper is standing next to the machine
that controls the gate and he disappears
before the blast later scenes show the
other characters morning and 11:00 moves
out of Hawkins with the buyers family so
here's why hopper is probably still
alive instead of rolling to the usual
end credits the camera pans over the
skyline of Kamchatka Russia the snowy
outcrop houses a mysterious Soviet
facility a soldier passes the doorway to
unlock a prisoner and another soldier
says no not the American they then
unlock a second door dragging a man out
and feeding him to a demagogue in it's
unclear if this is the same demagogue in
from season one there are very few
candidates for who the American could be
either it's a whole new character or
someone presumed dead in previous
seasons
dr. Brenner from season one was a
research scientist and Hawkins who was
killed by a demagogue on but in season
two a former lab employee tells 11 that
Brenna survived aside from him there
isn't anyone else whose death has
remained an ambiguity to such an extent
it seems too much of a coincidence that
the Soviets call hopper the American all
the season of course that this to be
hopper he would have had to survive the
blast in the Star Court more basement we
know that he wasn't able to get back
through the glass divide Joyce because
of the electrical charge caused by the
machine after Gregory's death in the
opening of the season we see exactly
what happens to anyone in the blast
radius
their bodies are over Tate
can buy blue tendrils of energy
apparently electrocuted this also occurs
immediately after the machine is
detonated this is different with hopper
we don't actually see any physical
effects from the blast we see just
vanishes here is where he stood when
choice turns the keys look again one
second after she turns them he's not
standing there anymore most important
the blast in episode 1 leaves behind
bodies we see the technicians getting
fried and then spot their corpses
whereas there isn't even a partially
melted moustache for hopper hopper is
also standing extremely close to the
gate within jumping distance of the
upside down if he is still alive he
could have climbed down the ladder and
jumped into the crack before it closed
the room goes black for a few seconds
then the lights come back on contrast
this with a nearly continuous blinding
light from episode 1 so the next
question how would the Soviets have
gotten hopper out of the upside-down
we know they have been studying the gate
as we saw in episode 1 we also see in
the mid credit scene that they have
access to the beings from the upside
down
ie a demagogue bin they could have also
gone back into the upside down and taken
hopper out hopper was in the upside down
a few times before so he may have been
able to survive there in season 2 hopper
and Dustin inhaled spores from the
upside down tunnel Dustin had his face
covered but hopper didn't and the side
effects of this has never really been
shown since that episode would war
effort was in these spores helped him
survive in the upside down after the
blast we see characters reacting to news
of Billy and hoppers deaths there's a WC
PK TV news segment that pops up assign
the previously read welcome to Hawkins
now reads
welcome to hell echoing hoppers final
line of season 3 see you in Hell teasing
a character death at the end of the
season isn't new to stranger things
in season one it was suggested 11 had
died only for her to return the same
song that plays at the end of this
season a version of heroes by David
Bowie also paid when we thought we'll
had died so stranger things have showed
away from a central character death for
nearly three seasons while supporting
cast members like barb barb and now
Billy potentially more disposable it's
difficult to imagine season four without
hopper the audience is teased with a
will they won't they storyline with
Joyce and hopper throughout this season
accumulating in their emotional glance
at one another through the partition
there seems to be little point in going
so far with this budding romance if
there won't be a true resolution Joyce
has already seen Bob her previous love
interest die so it would seem like lazy
writing to repeat this arc while xi is
packing she reads a letter its hoppers
speech to her and Mike that he wanted to
say to them but never did in episode 1
this speech encourages Elevens growth by
the pain that she suffered when life
hurts you because it will remember the
heard it also teases that Hopper is just
on the other side of a door for the sake
of your poor old dad keep the door open
three inches will 11 and her friends
have to reopen a door to get hopper back
what did you think about the ending
comment below
you
[Music]